foreign
good morning
um
um
so
um
folks
mr president madam vice president
i'm honored to be here today
representing
the more than three million women and
men of the department of defense
thank you so much for a welcoming
welcome us
and for making these historic
nominations
both of you lead by example
and the example that you set in all
things is one of inclusiveness
you know that diversity the diversity of
our nation
makes us stronger and that diversity in
our military ranks
makes us better at defending the
american people
just as critically you know that
leadership doesn't come conveniently
packaged
you know that it comes from lived
experience
everyone's lived experience
and today you are nominating for a
combatant command two
extraordinary military leaders whose
lived experience
encompasses nearly 70 years of uniformed
service
in peace and in war
they have known sacrifice they have
known loss
and they have known victory
they have flown and fought for this
country across the continents
from the waning days of the cold war
right up to the modern days of
wars that we still wage
richmond and europe to war together in
2003 as helicopter battalion commanders
flying dangerous missions over iraq
and also laura's brother and sister were
serving there too
securities thing of a family business
general van holtz general van novost was
a pioneer in the development of the
rugged c-17 cargo plane
conducting dirt takeoff and landings and
air drops in this mammoth aircraft
as one of its very first test pilots
in becoming a test pilot she also
achieved her dream of
flying fighter aircraft even though
women were
still barred from flying in combat
and undeterred she would later fly the
kc-135 tanker in combat
over the eyes of iraq and afghanistan
refueling numerous aircraft in support
of the joint force
each in their own way has been a
trailblazer
even if that wasn't the goal and each in
their own way
like you mr president and madam vice
president
has led by example and they still do
as general van ovos so eloquently put it
not long ago
it's important to have firsts and onlys
today mr president your nominations
ensure that all americans
women and men alike will see these two
special people continue to lead
at the highest levels they will see them
continue to defend this nation
and they will see as you like to say sir
the power of their example
and now it's my great pleasure to
introduce
another great leader the vice president
of the united states
kamala harris
mr president mr secretary
military and national security leaders
we're here today
for an extremely important occasion
at this moment we face global threats to
our climate
and our health to our physical security
and cyber security our capacity to meet
this moment
is determined both by our diplomatic
strength and by our ability
to build a strong smart and sustainable
military force
a force that recruits the most talented
a force that retains the most capable
a force that advances the best of the
best
general jacqueline ben oboest
and lieutenant general laura richardson
are some of the best and in fact i would
say the best of the best
general van ovost graduated from the
united states air force academy in 1988
since then she has logged more than 4
200 hours in the air
and she serves today as commander of the
air mobility
command lieutenant general richardson
was commissioned into the united states
army aviation branch
in 1986. she has flown
blackhawks and commanded battalions
and today she serves as commanding
general
of the united states army north
general van ovost and lieutenant general
richardson
have been tested under the most
difficult circumstances
and they are proven leaders
the president and i have full confidence
in them
to address the complex threats we face
to help lead our troops and to keep
our nation safe as it is international
women's day
i should also mention that general van
ovost and lieutenant general richardson
are but two of the many many women who
have defended our nation
throughout our history during the
american revolution
women rode horseback through enemy
territory
to transport sensitive military
information
during the civil war women disguised
themselves as men
and fought for the union army in world
war
ii women served as spars as
wax as waves and wasps
and today women military members
are stationed around the world
i say this to remind us while it has
only been five years
since all combat jobs have opened to
women
women have been in the line of fire
risking their lives
to protect our nation long before that
today we know women make up 16 percent
of our active duty military
and 19 percent of our enlisted officers
we also know that women want to serve
and that our military is stronger
when they do look no further
than general venovost and lieutenant
general richardson
for proof recruiting more women to our
military
adjusting policies to retain more women
enforcing policies to protect women and
ensure
they are heard and advancing more women
on fair and equal footing will without
any question
make our nation safer
and that's the work ahead so for now let
me congratulate
general van ovost and lieutenant general
richardson
and with that it is my great honor to
introduce
our commander-in-chief president joe
biden
thank you madam vice president
and thank you mr secretary on
friday i submitted to the senate
for confirmation my first slate of
nominations for
four star command positions and our
armed forces
among them two outstanding and eminently
qualified
warriors and patriots
general jacqueline van o'lest and
united states air force is currently the
only
officer reality i nominated her as
commander of united states station com
when kerm the lieutenant general laura
richardson of the united states army
will be promoted
the rank and joined general van o'hrest
as the only
four star as another four-star general
i nominated her as commander united
states southern command
and when confirmed they will become the
second and third women in the history of
the united states
armed forces to lead combatant commands
each of these women have led careers
demonstrating
incomparable skill integrity and
duty to country and and at every step
they've also helped push open the doors
of opportunity
to women in our military blazing the
trail
a little wider a little brighter
for all proud women following in their
path
and looking to their example and i
wanted to shine the light on these
accomplishments for those
women today because general van
ovost a is reiterated in an interview
this last week i'm the second person
that said
it's hard to be what you can't
see it's hard to be what you can't see
but you'll soon see today
is international women's day and we all
need to see and to recognize the
barrier-breaking accomplishments of
these women
we need the young women just beginning
their careers in the military service to
see it
and know that no door will be closed to
them
we need women and men throughout the
ranks
to see and celebrate women's
accomplishments and leadership in the
services
we need little girls and boys both who
have grown up
dreaming of serving for their country to
know this is what
generals in the united states armed
forces look like
this is what vice presidents of the
united states look like
so i'd like to spend just a few minutes
today
making sure that america knows who
general van ovos
is and lieutenant general richardson is
they're aviators both learn to fly
planes before they're old enough to
drive a car
general van ovos the first generation is
a first generation american
the daughter of dutch immigrants who
owned a flying operation
she loved freedom of flight and as a
teenager flew herself to see
sally ride lift off as the first
woman in space
16 years old goes down to see
sally ride she said she several thousand
watching a distance you know
women weren't were banned from flying
combat missions
when the general joined the force so she
focused on becoming a test pilot
and instead of learning to fly just one
plane she learned to fly
everything including air force two when
i was vice president
general van ovest currently as uh
overseas air mobility command
approximately one hundred and seven
thousand airmen
and one thousand one hundred planes that
enable america's air power
and humanitarian assistance to go
everywhere in the world
from flying water to texas after the
recent storms to ensuring our wounded
warriors are
evacuated from medical care from
anywhere in the world
she gets it done lieutenant general
richardson's parents were proud patriots
and mother wrote off the generalization
and her brother and sister all
joined the army her father encouraged
her to join rotc in college
even though that meant commuting to a
different school
when lieutenant general richardson
joined the army aviation branch
women were banned from flying attack
helicopters
she flew to in support of combat combat
missions
and uh and conducting lift operations
over
ue one the so-called ue and the
blackhawks
now as a commanding general of the
united states
army north lieutenant general richard
oversees military
ground responses here in north america
all over all over the last year
that's me terry nicole pernell deployed
to help on our response to this pandemic
more than 4 500 military medical
personnel
deployed in hospitals across 14 states
in the navajo nation to treat cova 19
patients
it means more than 2 200 medical
personnel
are working or soon will be at
vaccination sites in eight states
and the united states virgin islands i'm
so proud of the incredible
work lieutenant general richardson and
her team have
done to support the american people this
year and the american people are as well
they're warriors
they're crisis-tested commanders the
best of all
the best of all they're not done yet
neither these incredible generals
is resting on her laurels are on her
stars
they're using their voices and actively
working to change
policies in the military to make it
easier
and safer for more women not just to
join the military
but to stay in the military and to
thrive
i'm incredibly proud that in 2015 under
the obama biden administration week the
final steps
to open up all positions in the military
to anyone qualified to serve in them
the women who joined today's military
aren't told no
when they fight photojets for attack
helicopters
just because of their they aren't told
no when they want to apply to
ranger school or infantry officer basic
training
but they all know that there's much much
more work to be done
to ensure that women's leadership is
recognized
and we have more diverse leaders we
reach the top echelons of command
for all who are qualified including all
women all women and that all women feel
safe and respected
in our military period
you know some of some of it's relatively
uh
straightforward work where we're making
good progress
designing body armor that fits women
properly
tailoring combat uniforms for women
creating maternity flight suits or
updating
updating requirements for their
hairstyles
and some of it is going to take and
uh you know it's an intensity
of purpose and mission to really change
the culture and habits
that cause women to leave the military
that women are making sure more diverse
candidates are considering
being considered for career advancing
opportunities
at every single level the women aren't
penalized
in their careers for having children
that women aren't just
token members but integral parts
throughout all branches and all
divisions
and that they can completely fairly
engage in promotion compete all across
the board including
on the uh on age and gender neutrality
and physical fitness
you know that both members of the uh
of the uh of the military
uh couples can thrive while serving
like lieutenant general richardson and
her husband lieutenant general
richardson
who i might add i want to thank you for
getting me off a mountain
that was about 12 to 14 000 feet up on a
goat path
when our helicopter went down in the
snowstorm it's good to see it general
the ride down that mountain was more
perilous in the truck than it was in a
helicopter but thank you
and we have to take on sexual assault
and harassment
and violence against women in the
military sexual assault is abhorrent and
wrong at any time
and in our military so much of unit
cohesion is built on trusting your
fellow service members
to have your back there's nothing less
than a threat to our national security
i know secretary austin takes this as
seriously as vice president harris and i
do
that's why this first memo as secretary
was a directive to take on sexual
assault in the military
and why he stepped up independent review
he set up an independent review
commission on sexual assault
to make concrete recommendations for
changes
this is going to be an all hands on deck
effort
under my administration to end the
scourge of sexual assault in the
military
and we're going to be focused on that
from the very top
i know that we can do it the u.s
military has defeated american enemies
on land and air and at sea
and this is not beyond us
i want to thank the general vanovis
and lieutenant general richardson for
their exemplary careers in service to
our country
your america's patriotism at its finest
undaunted and absolutely
absolutely able to do anything by any
obstacle
determined to open wide the doors of
opportunity
and ready for the next challenge it's my
great honor to serve as your
commander-in-chief
i look forward to hearing your active
duty and recommendations of
how we work together to keep the
american people safe
meet every challenge in the 21st century
so i want to thank you
both and i want to thank the the the
former general i keep calling him
general my
my uh the guy who runs that outfit over
there
i want to make sure we thank the
secretary
for all he's done to try to implement
what we just talked about
and for recommending these two women for
promotion
thank you all may god bless you all and
may god protect our troops
[Music]
thank you everybody mr president can you
pass voting rights with the senate pull
up the filibuster in its current form do
you think
i can talk to you about that what about
these votes against transgender you
you cry
appreciate it